Days of Our Lives star James listovic
has been found safe and sound after
going missing in Hawaii with his
roommate Nevin desdari Joey
why didn't you guys let me know you were
coming on Tuesday Nevin's sister posted
the update to social media explaining
that the two got lost on a hike but made
it to their car and were on their way
back to their Resort in Kauai quote
thank you to everyone for reposting and
helping us reach Nevin
on Monday James's mom Lucien posted to
Instagram revealing that James and Nevin
went missing Sunday after telling a
staff member at the resort that they
were heading to koki State Park where
they were going to do a long trail hike
they also asked for directions to
Shipwreck Beach specifically the cliff
diving area according to Lucien who
ended up flying out to Kauai to search
for the pair the actor and his roommate
were scheduled to be back in La Monday
but never arrived after their day out
the two did not return to the resort
leaving behind all of their belongings
which have since been turned over to the
police
at the time Lucien posted this snap and
in the caption she asked for anyone who
had information about their whereabouts
to contact authorities
quote they were due to fly back today
but never made their flight nor returned
to their rental car this is not like
them they are both conscientious kids
[Music]
on Tuesday after they were located
Lucian shared a positive update telling
fans on Instagram that James and Nevin
are exhausted dehydrated and scraped up
but playfully added after a good night's
rest and an island Pizza I think the
world will seem right side up again
foreign